en este edificio de kiev andreícovalenco
utiliza velas y antorchas para tener luz
en su casa como él entre 1,5 y 2
millones de personas o cerca de la mitad
de la población de la capital
periódicamente se ven sumidos en la
oscuridad Ya que las autoridades
alternan la electricidad de un Distrito
a otro
ya hemos comprado un generador tiene que
ser entregado tal vez mañana o después
de mañana
tengo que trabajar mi mujer tiene que
trabajar los niños estudian a distancia
y no podemos dejarlos solos en el
apartamento
las autoridades ucranianas afirman que
los repetidos ataques con misiles rusos
dirigidos a las infraestructuras
energéticas de todo el país han
paralizado casi la mitad de la red de
energía en algunas zonas las autoridades
han forzado los apagones para hacer
frente a la situación
las dificultades de suministro
energético persisten en 17 y en la
capital la región de kiev y la ciudad de
kiev las regiones de odesa vinicia y
ternópil tienen muchas dificultades
Héctor
ha caído la primera Nevada del invierno
y el descenso de las temperaturas está
presionando la red eléctrica el Primer
Ministro ucraniano pidió más apoyo a
Europa incluida ayuda financiera para
comprar más gas la ONU dice que está
proporcionando generadores junto a otros
socios sobre todo a los hospitales y a
los centros de desplazados